world championship tournament with Anand
uh was it easier harder roughly as
expected well first of all I I had a
long time to prepare uh I prepared a lot
but I think it probably scared me a
little bit to to go through all of
anan's games from the past because I
realized how extremely strong uh how
diverse his strengths are when I got to
the first game I was a little bit
nervous um I played a little bit of an
offbeat line but which I thought could
still give me a slight advantage and he
replied quite quickly uh and um I had to
basically beg for a draw with white
pretty early on and um that made me even
more nervous uh and scared because I
thought if he's that well prepared even
in some off beit sideline then what the
hell am I supposed to to do